the size of a dahlia becomes very clear
from space 28 counties in Florida have
issued evacuation orders for their
coastal cities that's millions of people
impacted people are out to find Higher
Ground before the hurricane hits I tell
them to leave
everyone
there
that's what the county said that's what
the state said and that's what my
director says Lee so I am not to deviate
from that
because we want you to be alive
they're boarding up filling up and
packing up stores have been cleared of
essential supplies at this Hospital in
Tampa crews are building a three meter
Aqua wall to protect from storm surge
and flooding but for many others
sandbags will be the last line of
defense I'm feeling fine right now
obviously we're on the bad side of it
um but worst case is flooding right now
hopefully not too much wind damage the
only tip I would say is with so many
more people moving into Florida
if you're planning to get away you start
ahead of time because the traffic it's
no kidding it's horrible this is going
to be a major hurricane likely a
category three and it's where it's
scheduled to hit along this big bend and
we've not really had a hurricane strike
this area for a long long time I think
you got to go back to the 1800s before
you would see a path like this the
hurricane has already swept over Cuba
not as strong as it will be over Florida
but enough to cause damage
My Two children and I went through a
really rough time inside our home we
needed to leave this place at 2 A.M
because everything was wet the
mattresses the beds the quilts were
drenched everything was drenched
the National Weather Service says
Florida is facing a life-threatening
dangerous situation with potential Winds
of 170 kilometers per hour it will get
stronger as it moves to the Florida
coast people are being warned they
should expect to spend several days
surviving on their own Alan Fisher Al
Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera